Today we look at the question of
success. Okay, the question is who
succeeds
and why?
Okay, so we we've done a lot of research
and we've discovered that people who who
succeed
um succeed for certain reasons.
So there is a Colombia psychologist
named Walter Mitchell
and he devised a very famous experiment
called the marshmallow test.
In the marshmallow test, it's very very
easy. Okay. So imagine a room and I
invite a fouryear-old or 5-year-old to
come into this room and have a
conversation with him or her. I ask him,
"How's your mother? What do you like to
do?" And it's a very good conversation.
Then suddenly I get up and say, "I'm
really sorry, but I need to go across
the hallway for another meeting, but
I'll be back. Okay? So just wait for me.
And here and here, I'll make you a deal.
Here's a marshmallow. I'm going to put a
marshmallow in front of you.
and you can have it right now, but if I
come back and the marshmallow is still
there, I will give you two marshmallows.
Okay? And and then uh Walter Mitchell,
he goes away and he goes behind the room
and for a seeth through mirror, he's
able to see the students as they
struggle to contain themselves because
obviously they want two marshmallows.
And there are some students who can in
fact resist the temptation to eat the
first marshmallow and then a second
marshmallow. But then there are others
who cannot.
And Walter Mitchell will spend 50 years
just tracking them. Okay. What he
discovers is this. The students who
resist the temptation who get the second
marshmallow there are much more likely
to do better in school. They have higher
test scores. They have better careers.
their careers are more stable. They get
promoted in their careers. They're much
more able to find a stable relationship.
Um they avoid jail. They avoid drugs.
They avoid alcohol. They're more lean.
They're more fit. They live longer,
better teeth. And those who cannot
resist
and eat the first marshmallow right
away, they have the opposite effect.
Okay? And so the idea is that for Walter
Mitchell, success
means
delayed
gratification.
And all this means is that people who
succeed are capable of longterm
planning.
To succeed today, I will make sacrifices
necessary.
Okay. So RA, so if my friends are
playing outside and I need to do my
homework, well, I'm going to stay home,
do my homework. Okay, so long-term
planning, what he calls delayed
gratification.
Or a much more simple way of saying this
is the idea of self-control,
right? Or the idea of emotional
regulation.
[snorts] You're able to keep your
emotions in check.
If you're angry, you're able to calm
yourself down.
Okay? And so we've tried, we know about
this and that's why in school we focus
on the idea of emotional regulation,
teaching you how to better control your
emotions, how to do long-term planning.
Okay,
so that's one theory of success. Another
theory of success comes to us from
another psychologist named Carol Dwight
and she's at Stanford and she wrote a
book called Mindset.
Okay. And what she tells us is that
those who succeeded in life have a
growth mindset
and those who fail in life have a fixed
mindset.
Okay. And it's not hard. Okay. The the
idea is resilience.
Those of a growth mindset, if they fall
or they fail, they say to themselves,
"This opportunity for me to learn, so
I'm going to think about what I did
wrong. Next time I'll do better."
And a fixed mindset are people who
cannot accept the idea of failure. who
think that it's because they're not
capable of improving and therefore they
give up. Okay? So those with a growth
mindset,
if they fail, they try harder. Those who
have a fixed mindset, if they fail, they
just give up.
And so the idea of resilience, okay,
pretty simple, right?
And the third idea of success comes to
us from K. Anders Ericson who is a
Swedish psychologist and she wants to
know why certain people are able to
succeed as musicians or athletes and he
creates the idea of deliberate practice.
Okay. So what he found is that people
who want to become athletes or musicians
they work really hard. They practice
every day. But the people who succeed
practice strategically.
Okay? So those who uh work hard just
work a long time. But those who work
strategically
have a plan. The plan is this. What are
my goals?
How can I achieve these goals?
And then how do I improve my plan?
Okay. So, they're examining their own
practices and they're trying to figure
out where the weaknesses are, where they
can improve. Instead of plan
on how to improve and then they follow
his plan and if this plan helps them
improve, they stick to a plan. But if
the plan doesn't really work, they
change the plan as well. Okay. So, this
is the idea of selfreflection.
or selfassessment
constantly thinking about
how you are as a student and figure out
figure out how to improve your own
learning strategies. And what Kersner
Ericson discovered is that if you do
this, you'll succeed at anything. And
this is true. Okay? Right. And the the
reason why we know it's true is there
are two American psychologists named
Dunning Dunning and Krueger
something the Dunning Krueger effect.
And so what they did was this. They ran
an experiment. They have 500 students in
their psychology class first year
university. They made every student take
an IQ test.
And then after they took the IQ test,
they asked each student, "How do you
think you did on the IQ test? Do you
place in the top 5% or the bottom 5%."
And it turns out that no one got the
ranking
correct. Okay, so those who were in the
top 5%
um in terms of IQ thought they were
maybe in the top 20%. Because for them
it was easy. So they assumed everyone
for everyone else it was easy as well.
But what was um dramatic is that those
who scored the lowest thought they were
average. Okay? So the worst 5% in the
class thought they were in the top 50%
or just average.
And the easy and the reason why is those
people who are stupid lack the capacity
to know they're stupid.
Okay. So what Dunning Kuba discovered is
that the hardest part of being a student
is to assess yourself properly
to know exactly where you stand and how
to improve. Those who are stupid are
often the most confident in the world.
That's what what's called the Dunning
Krueger effect. And this is this helps
explain why the world is why it is
because often the people in power are
stupid. They don't know they're stupid.
They were confident and they do stupid
things like [clears throat] Donald
Trump. Okay. All right. All right. So
now we have these three theories, right?
We have self-control, we have
resilience, and we have self assessment.
And which and and so as educators, as
schools, what we can do is deise
strategies
and curriculum to help students all
succeed. Correct? Right.
The problem is that when we actually try
this, it doesn't work.
Okay? If you take a bad student and you
teach him self-control,
resilience, and self assessment, the
student doesn't actually get better.
The reason why is okay and this is a
very important idea for you guys to
remember is that correlation
does not equal causation.
Okay, you guys you guys need to remember
this. Just because things are correlated
does not mean they cause each other. So
I'll give you an example. We know that
successful people they get up early in
the morning. Okay, they get up at four
o'clock in the morning. But just because
you get up at four o'clock in the
morning does not mean you'll succeed.
Okay,
just because you work hard, just because
you're resilient,
just because you have growth mindset
does not mean you'll succeed.
But if you're successful, you will get
up early in the morning because you're
more you are more motivated.
If you are successful in life, you will
have more cons self self-control. You
will have uh more resilience. You you'll
be more humble. Okay, does that make
sense? So, if you're rich, guess what
happens? You become successful
and therefore you will have growth
mindset,
self-control,
deliberate practice. Okay, does that
make sense?
But just because you have growth
mindset, deliver practice
and resilience does not mean you'll
succeed.
Okay. So the question for us is why does
this happen and ultimately who succeeds?
Okay. So we know for a fact that rich
people are much more likely likely to
succeed than poor people.
And in fact, what we know from
macroeconomic studies is that school
doesn't really matter. Doesn't matter
how well you do in school. If your
parents are rich, you'll be successful
in life. If your parents are poor, you
will not be successful in life. Okay.
So, what's the difference? Okay. So, now
let's look at parenting strategies
between rich and poor.
Okay.
So there are lots of differences but
let's focus on three major differences.
The first major difference is that rich
parents
speak to their kids more
than poor parents. Okay. High vocab
vocabulary, low vocabulary.
When rich parents speak to the kids,
rich parents will use higher vocabulary,
longer sentences,
poor parents will just be no, yes, go
away.
Okay. Another major difference is in
attitude.
Okay. So rich parents use a friendly
attitude
and poor parents use an authoritarian
or command attitude.
So for example,
if you are a rich kid and you go and
touch a stove stove, okay, and you burn
your hand,
the rich parent will say, "Listen, you
made a mistake. Don't worry about it.
Let me explain to you why touching a
fire is bad for you because you'll burn
yourself
and you might have to go to doctor and
uh we will feel pain if you hurt
yourself. Okay? So the rich parent will
spend a lot of time explaining to the
child why this is wrong and how not to
do it again. The poor parent is like
don't you ever do that again or I'll
beat the crap out of you. Okay? Don't do
that. Pretty simple. Okay. But as you
can you can understand the rich kid will
understand that the world is safe and
that he is respected in this world.
Okay. Whereas the poor child will think
that the world is scary and he or she
must be afraid of adults. And this
carries on into school, right? Because
as a rich kid, you go into school and
you think that oh my teacher is my
friend. So you smile at the teacher and
you hug the teacher and the teacher
smiles back and now you're friends,
right? But if you're a poor kid and you
see the teacher, you don't you're afraid
to look at the teacher. You don't smile.
You're you are stressed. Okay? And the
teacher thinks that you might be a
problem child. So the problem with this
is that yes, being a third parent, it is
effective, but it creates stress in the
family.
Okay, it makes the child feel unsafe.
And this leads to our the third major
difference between rich parents and poor
parents. Rich parents offer stability.
Okay, poor parents can only offer
volatility.
This is a very simple idea. Rich parents
have money so they can afford to keep
promises.
So I'm rich parent. I say to my child,
"Okay, next week we'll go to Thailand
for vacation. Guess what? Next week you
go, you guys go to Thailand for
vacation." [snorts] But if you are a
poor parent, money is always an issue.
So, it's hard for you to keep promises,
right? So, it's like, "Next week, we'll
go to McDonald's for lunch, but your
paycheck um is not enough." So, you're
like, "Sorry, we can't go anymore."
Okay?
[snorts] And now because of these
different parenting styles, we
understand why
um rich kids behave different from poor
kids, right? So let's look at let's look
at the idea idea of self-control,
right? Self-control.
What is the marshmallow test?
Marshmallow test is not a test of
self-control. It's a test of your trust
in others. Right? If you believe that
the teacher who goes outside, if you
believe that he or she comes back and
will pro when will keep his or her
promise, then you will not eat that
marshmallow.
But if you think that this teacher is
lying to me, then you're not going to
eat that marshmallow. Then you will eat
that marshmallow. Right? So it's not
really about self-control. It's about
your belief and trust in authority
figures. Right? So if you're rich,
stability, you have stability. But if
you're poor, you don't have stability.
So you're actually better off eating
that marshmallow rather than waiting for
that second marshmallow. Because guess
what? Most of the time, you will not get
that second marshmallow. Okay? Do you do
you understand? So it's not that poor
kids are stupid. Poor kids are rational
and they're responding to the
circumstances that they live in.
Okay? and resilience, right? Well, the
idea of resilience is that you believe
that the world will help you,
right? So, if you're rich
and you believe that everyone helps you,
you can be resilient
because
if you fail, someone will help you get
up. If you're poor, if you fail, that
probably tells you you should be doing
this.
Okay, you probably won't succeed doing
this. So, you don't have you don't have
much confidence in others. Okay, and the
idea of self assessment, right? Looking
inward.
Well, if you're a poor child who lives
under a lot of stress, it's hard for you
to be self-reflective because if you
look back at yourself, all you think
about is your pain and your stress.
Okay. So from these different parenting
strategies, we can now explain why
different students behave the way they
do.
This of course may lead you to think,
okay, well then rather than construct
our schools around self-control,
resilience, and um self-reflection, we
should construct our schools around
better parenting skills. Okay? which
means that hey let's construct schools
where kids are exposed to a lot of
vocabulary uh where teachers are
friendly and where there's a lot of
stability. Okay.
And we've tried this and it's more
effective but it doesn't really work
either.
Why? Because the kids come in too late.
A lot of their worldview is already
established. Then you're like, "Okay,
well then let's change how parents
behave." And when you do that, what you
recognize is that nope, you can't change
how they behave either.
Okay? So no matter what you do, you end
up with massive differences between the
poor and the rich. The rich stay rich
and the poor stay poor. Okay? So now the
question for us is
why is this the case?
Okay.
And it's the case because
society is a hierarchy.
Okay. And the hierarchy is usually
divided between the rich and the poor.
Okay. And these two worlds are night and
day. They're very, very different. As a
poor person, if you want to survive, you
have to obey authority.
Okay? But if you're a rich person, the
way that you get along with others, the
way that you maximize
your outcome is by negotiating with
others. Okay? Negotiating.
Okay? So, negotiating can also mean
debate, right? So, who should be the
boss? Well, let's have a debate and
present different evidence as to to
figure out who's who should be the boss.
Okay. So, negotiation means debate
and argument.
So, this helps us this helps us
understand why different parents
parent their child differently. If
you're a poor parent, your
responsibility is to make sure that your
child knows how to obey authority. Okay?
That's why you command your child.
But if you are a rich parent, you want
your child to be able to negotiate with
authority. And that's why you respect
your child and you teach your child how
to debate, how to argue, how to
negotiate with others.
Okay? Because they live in different
worlds.
Another way of saying this is that
from day one,
rich kids know that they're playing a
different game than they're playing a
different game from poor kids. Okay. So,
[sighs and clears throat]
let's go back and look at parents.
Okay.
So
um
per poor parents command their child um
don't really speak, don't communicate.
Um and don't keep promises. Okay.
All right. So poor parents do these
three things. And we know that if they
do these three things, the outcome won't
be so good. Okay? And the reason why
they do this is that they're not playing
a game to improve their kids outcome.
They're playing a game to get along with
other parents.
Okay.
Okay. Colleagues,
family.
Okay. Authority.
Okay. So, another way of saying this is
this
police,
boss.
Okay. Family. Okay. All right. So, as a
parent, you're trying to figure out how
how to negotiate with the police, with
your boss, and with your family.
So, if you're a poor person, and the
police knows you're a poor person, the
police is going to bully you. And if you
fight back, the police will probably put
you in jail.
Okay? So, it's very important that you
accept authority. You don't challenge
authority because if you do, you'll
probably get into trouble.
Your boss, right? If you're a poor
person, your your boss will just command
you about. And so, it's very important
that your child knows how to take orders
rather than ask questions, rather than
debate. Your child must learn how to
just follow orders or at least keep his
mouth shut. Okay? And then family is
about maintaining good relations with
those who can most support you and that
often means the same values.
Okay? So if the if your family members
or your friends if they are ch if they
are parenting their child in this manner
you're also going to copy them okay
imitation.
All right and for a poor person this is
the optimal strategy
of how to parent.
[snorts]
Okay, does it make sense guys?
Because if you do another way, okay, if
you are if you choose to uh be a friend
to your child,
if you choose to communicate, if you
choose to keep your promises,
then
the your friends and your family will
think that you're doing something wrong.
You understand? They they won't think,
"Oh my god, you are an enlightened
parent who's read a lot of parenting
books and great for you." They're going
to think there's something wrong with
you. Okay, so let let me give you an
example of this.
Let me give you an example of this.
So
my wife and I have three kids. Okay,
my parenting style.
So my wife and I have three kids and
this is how we parent our kid. Okay.
First of all, we
have our child we give our child a lot
of freedom.
So So we don't have our kids do
activities. Okay? We don't have our kids
do lots lots of lots of activities.
We don't send our kids to math class. We
don't send our kids to swimming class.
We don't send our kids to piano class.
Okay? We just let our kids run around
and play.
The other thing that we do is we
communicate a lot with our child. Okay.
Communication. We believe in democracy
in our in our family. If there's if
we're going to make a decision together,
we want everyone to communicate
together.
Okay. Um so
a normal Chinese family will just have a
very tight schedule, right? And then the
other thing that we do that's different
is we tell stories.
The other Chinese families will do math.
Okay? So we raise our children in a way
that's very different from normal
Chinese families from the way that you
you've been raised. Okay? And we do this
because both my wife and I, we spend a
lot of time talking about parenting.
I've read a lot of books about
parenting.
I spent many decades researching the
best education possible. And so that's
why we raise our children in this way.
And guess what? Because we do this, we
have no friends in China. We have
family, but they all think we're crazy.
Okay?
But we do this because for us, what's
most important is to make sure that our
children are happy and healthy and that
they have a chance to be creative and be
successful in life. Because I think that
if you do it this way, the child will
not be creative, will not be successful.
But if you do it this way, your child
will fit in into China better.
Okay?
So parenting the goal, the incentive is
not for your child to succeed.
It's the incentive is for your child to
fit into China
or the larger social environment that
you are in.
Okay? And that's why it's very hard to
change the way people behave. And that's
why social structures are extremely
rigid because the game they're playing
is often just to fit into their
environment. Okay. Does that make sense
guys? Okay. Any questions before I move
on? Uh yep.
>> Thanks. Uh so so for poor families, is
there any way for the poor kids to be
succeed to be the the rich parents you
describe in the future?
Yeah.
>> Okay. That's that's a really good
question. Okay. Um so we know that there
are certain poor kids who do succeed.
For example, I'm a poor kid who
succeeded. My um we imig immigrated to
Toronto, Canada when I was like 6 years
old and my father was a dishwasher. So
we were very poor family. Okay. And but
I succeeded
because I left Canada for the United
States.
So Canada is a very rigid place where
poor people basically move up a bit but
not too far
but I was able to succeed because I was
able to get a scholarship to go study in
the United States. Okay. So there are
opportunities. The problem though is
that it means leaving your community.
Okay? Does that make sense? So one way
to succeed is to abandon your community.
Okay. But that's high risk,
right?
So you have to be extremely
individualistic
to take such a risk.
So that's why most most people don't do
it because you think about it, the
safest option for you is to stay within
your community.
that's what's going to guarantee you uh
the most the the best outcome. But if
you choose to abandon your community and
just say and just say, you know what,
I'm going to go somewhere else and try
my try my luck. That's taking a really
high risk. Okay. So you to succeed, you
have to take high risk. So another
possibility is war.
um that traditionally historically has
been
uh the best mechanism of social
mobility. When you when you go fight a
war and you do really well, you'll get
promoted in life.
Okay.
But again, war is high risk because
chances are you'll get killed. Okay? So,
not just war, but also revolution,
right?
Okay. And of course
um the best way of course is to marry
up. Marrying up.
Okay. And that's why remember remember
in our very first class we talked about
the dating game, right? Where women
only want five and four. Okay. The
reason why is that five and four are
high status.
and 321 are low status.
So if you're a woman, you don't want to
marry into a low status family because
your children will be screwed over.
Okay? Your best option is to take a
risk, gamble into a high stat and marry.
You want you want to try to marry into a
high status family. Okay? So
traditionally
um war and marrying up are the two major
mechanisms of social mobility in today's
world. Um
uh abandoning community can also lead to
success. Okay. Basically immigrating to
a place that offers more social social
mobility which often means United
States. Okay. But another way of saying
this is you have to get really lucky
guys.
Okay, so there's lots of poor people who
think that you know I succeeded because
I worked hard and I'm really talented.
Look, I was born poor. I lucked into
Yale. Okay, it's luck.
You can work out, you can work as hard
as you want, but the chances are are
against you.
Okay. And it takes a certain personality
which is you're really individualistic.
You're very ambitious and you have high
risk tolerance. Most people don't have
that. Okay. So yes, there are certain
people who despite their background,
they're able to succeed, but that's
often the exception to the rule as
opposed to the rule itself. Okay. So So
thank you. Is this clear?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Any more questions, guys, before I
move on?
>> Okay.
Can be luck counted as a kind of ability
or is just coincidence?
>> Okay, that's a really good question.
Yeah. Okay.
Yep.
So,
you're absolutely right. Okay. So, luck
is a form of strategy.
Okay. strategy
and all this is saying is that you are
trying to position yourself in a place
that allows you to get lucky.
Okay? So I left Canada and I went to
United States because I knew that in
Canada doesn't matter how hard you work
no one cares. But in the United States,
if you work really hard, then you might
get lucky and you might meet someone
who's like, "Wow, you're a really hard
worker. I want to promote you." Okay.
So, so you're right in that yes, you can
strategize and increase your luck, but
it's still luck.
All right? And those who succeed
are able to think strategically and far
ahead and position themselves
in a way that allows them to get lucky.
Okay? And they often have the
characteristics that we talked about,
you know, like so self-control,
resilience, and the ability to look
inward and better understand what you're
good at.
Okay.
So it takes a combination of factors.
But the point I'm trying to make is that
these people are only a minority are a
minority. Okay. 1% of the population
really.
Okay. And they still depend on luck.
Any more questions before I move on?
Okay. So this leads us to a question
which is okay. Well, the way that I
frame everything, okay, the way that I
frame everything, you have poor and you
have rich.
And as discussed, they live in their own
world worlds and they don't really
connect with each other. They have
different parenting strategies. They
have different outlooks. The rich stay
with themselves, the poor stay amongst
themselves. So, this looks like a very
stable system, right? Stability
or the word we can use is equilibrium.
Now the question then is
why do societies collapse? Why are there
revolutions?
Why are there social changes? This looks
like an like a system of equilibrium
where because of parenting people know
their place and people know how to best
strategize about maintaining their
place. So why are they why is there
social change?
And the reason why is that this system
has problems and it's stable. But the
main problem is this system. Okay, it's
it's the rich that's problematic. And
the reason why is that the rich are
taught from day one to negotiate a
better outcome.
Okay. So know another know another way
of saying this is that the poor is like
minimum
outcome. Okay. The rich want the maximum
outcome.
The poor are like you know what if I'm
you know if I'm alive if I have a decent
job I'm okay. the [snorts] but the rich
are like no I need to be the top dog I
need to improve my lot in society
otherwise what's the point of my life
okay so they have high expectations okay
high expectations
low expectations
okay and this is a problem because
power it's a zero- sum
Okay, hierarchy is a zero sum game. So
only a few people can be at the top. So
eventually you get a you get into a
situation where there are too rich
people, too many few too many rich
people and not enough powerful
positions. And this this is what's
called elite overp production.
Okay. And then what happens here is that
in order to
um get power certain factions of the
rich will align with certain factions of
the poor against the um powers that be.
Okay. So all revolutions are always
between the
have a lot versus have some. It's never
between rich and poor. It's always
between half a lot and half some.
So the people who led the Chinese
revolution, right, people like Mudon,
join Lai, Don Ping, they were not poor
people. They didn't come from poor
families, but they weren't rich enough.
Okay, so the Chinese revolution was
really between the urban elite versus
the rural elite. Okay, the have a lot
versus have some. If you look at every
revolution in human history, that's
always been the case.
Okay? If you go back to Chinese history
and you look at all these revolutions
that started in China, it was it was
always led by
um the middle class or the aspirational
class, usually merchants, right?
Merchants, because they were
discriminated heavily in society, but
they had money and they wanted to
transform their money into power. And so
when times were bad, when people were
looking for change, they took the
initiative and led people into
revolution.
Okay.
Okay. Does it make sense, guys?
All right. Any questions?
Yeah.
>> All right.
>> [clears throat]
>> So you said the revolution was uh
initiate be uh within those rich people.
So how could they lead the poor people
to to to vote to follow them to start
the revolution because revolution need a
huge amount of people like the public
face to um like yeah to to initiate.
>> Okay.
Okay, great question. Okay, so
revolutions are almost the same.
So over time because of the structure
because of the inequality between rich
and poor certain problems arise. Okay.
So and these problems are extremely
common.
The first problem okay problems
the first problem is indebtedness.
Because the rich have a monopoly over
wealth. For the poor to survive, they
need to borrow money.
But over time, because of interest
rates,
the poor find themselves in slavery.
Okay?
Because if you can't afford to pay back
the bank or the rich person then your
body is collateral. Okay. So you become
a slave but not only do you become
become a slave but your children become
slaves as well. So slavery becomes a
very common problem. And then the third
issue of course is landlessness.
Okay. So these are the three most common
problems that ultimately become the
seeds of revolution. Um the poor get
into debt and so they lose their land
and their children become slaves. The
children their children's children
become slaves as well. Okay? Because
because of interest rates it's
impossible for you to pay back that
debt.
Okay? So now you have a majority of
people who have absolutely no incentive
to live.
So what happens now is that
um a elite okay
say to these people follow me
into revolution and I will clear your
debts.
I will give you land and I will end
slavery and that's it. Okay. Every
single revolution has been like this.
There have been different names. Okay.
So for example, communists are like
we'll create a communist paradise.
What's a communist paradise? A communist
paradise is where debt is canceled,
where people are given land and where no
one's a slave. Okay. Then others like
okay we'll create a religious paradise.
Islam. Okay. So Muhammad
um the Islamic Revolution was about this
initially later on it changed right and
Muhammad said to everyone we're going to
create the kingdom of heaven what's the
kingdom of heaven the kingdom of heaven
is where people don't have debt where
people have land to feed themselves and
where there are no slaves so if you are
a Muslim you can never be a slave
okay so look at every single revolution
it's this pattern where over time
because of inequality in society, you
have uh people who fall into too much
debt. They become slaves. They have no
land. And then because of elite overp
production, you have this faction that
splinters off
and who in order to um obtain power, get
the people on their side. Okay? And you
look at the Roman civil war, Julius
Caesar was was saying the same thing,
right? Why was he so popular? because he
was saying to the Roman people, if I
become king, I will get rid of your
debt. I will free you of slavery and I
will give you land. And that's why they
had to kill him. Hey,
why is Donald Trump so popular in
America right now? Same thing, man.
Where Americans are in debt to their
credit cards, student loans, their
houses, and so
they believe that Donald Trump were to
come to power. If you want to become
king, what's the first United King does?
What the first United King always does
is cancel all debts. Because if you
cancel all debts, who loses power? It's
the rich who lose power. And it's the
rich who almost dangerous to a king.
Okay. Does that make sense?
Okay. So, so again, this is a very
similar pattern in human history. It's
all game theory. Okay.
Any [snorts]
more questions guys?
Okay, ask one more one more question
that then we'll break. Okay, is this
clear to you guys?
>> Okay, so another way of understanding
this is that according to game theory,
individuals don't really matter. Okay,
you have to look at large groups. You
have to look at large large social
trends. Okay, you cannot really change
the outcome for certain groups of people
like poor kids unless you look at the
overall structure in which they they
live.
Okay,
one more question guys then we'll break
for the day.
Yeah. Alan.
So like is that the
uh the society or like just the elite
that really rule the country who really
have the power have the motivations to
maintain a society that a certain degree
of social mobility is allowed but not
all of them. But but but not a really a
big social mobility. So that first
firstly they can maintain their power
but second like they give the lower
class people a hope to get into the rich
class uh but not using like revolutions
or other things that will like turn this
society into collapse.
>> Okay. Yeah.
Okay. Look, you're absolutely right. So
social mobility
is really the best form of governance,
right?
>> As long as you enable people with talent
and ability and ambition to climb up,
they'll be happy and your society will
be very stable. But not only will be
very stable, it will be very prosperous,
very creative. It doesn't matter what
system you have. Okay? So the example is
okay America 1950s was a democracy and
there's a lot of social mobility
um and so people worked really hard and
America became very wealthy
but guess what in China 1950s
China was not democracy it was it was a
communist system but in 1950s people
worked really hard as well why because
China was destroyed after decades of war
and there were lots of opportunities for
social mobility. If you worked hard, you
got promoted very quickly in the system.
So even though it was a communist
system, not a capitalist system, even
though it was it was it was a commanding
economy rather democracy, people worked
really hard because they thought that by
working hard they can improve their
lives. So social mobility is the best
form of governance. You don't need
democracy. You don't need any any
system. Okay? As long as you have social
mobility, people will be happy.
The problem though is that over time
less than a generation all the positions
of power are failed. Okay. So the people
with talent [snorts] who made the
country great who made the country
wealthy when they when they get into
power
they don't want people like them
to replace them. They want their
children to replace them.
Okay. And over time these children are a
lot. So what happens is at the very top
all the positions are filled and there's
a waiting list as well.
So if you are a poor person who is who
works hard, really talented,
unfortunately all those positions at the
top are filled already and the wait and
there's also waiting list. So too bad.
Okay. And this is and again you just
look at Chinese history right? Look at
Chinese history where at the beginning
of the dynasty you had all these
talented people take the civil civil uh
entrance examination the kju and these
are really taught people but then what
happens is that they they have children
and they teach their children how to do
on the kju and then eventually they're
like you know what we'll just cheat. So
they corrupt the kju
and then eventually like you know what
screw this whoever can pay to pass a kju
will pass a kju and then all the
positions at the very top are filled
there's no more social mobility so what
do people do they engage in revolution
right so you look at hio tren
right he he failed the kju or he there
was no position at the top for him so he
started so he believed He became
brother, brother of Jesus, right? And he
started this revolution that claimed
tens of millions of lives in China. Why?
Because there was no social mobility for
him. 50 years ago prior, he would have
been a he would have been a civil
servant. Same thing for Maong, right? By
the time that Maong became a university
student, the ku had been eliminated. So
there's no way for him to climb the
ladder anymore. Therefore, he had to
start engaging in new ideas.
Okay.
So, you're absolutely right in that
social social mobility is the best way
to maintain social harmony,
but people have children and they want
the children to succeed and they will
arrange a system in a way that only
their children can succeed, which screws
over every other children, every
everyone else. And so they have no
choice but to overthrow the system.
Okay? Or another way of saying this is
game reset.
Game reset. [snorts]
This is what a revolution is. Okay. So
another way another way of saying this
is that
100 people are playing a game, 10 people
are winning and they keep on winning and
they can only win. So everyone else is
like screw this game let's start a new
game and the 10 people are like nope
we're happy playing this game they can't
agree so the United people can only the
only thing they can do is a revolution
which allows for game reset which now
again allows for social mobility
and that is the course of human history.
Okay.
Either you
um climb up the ladder. If they don't
allow you to climb up climb up the
ladder, then you'll just break the game.
Okay. So, but unfortunately, again,
[sighs]
once you're in power, you want your
children to inherit your power. And so,
you will rig the game in a way that only
your children can succeed. Okay? And
that's why the school that's that's why
the schools are the way they are.
Okay, schools for the rich are very
different from the very different from
schools for the poor, right? Schools for
the rich, there's a lot of freedom,
there's a lot of creativity, the
teachers are very good. You go to poor
schools and it's the complete opposite.
And the reason why is the system is set
up to make sure that certain people
succeed and everyone else fails.
Okay, does that make sense, Alan?
>> Okay, great. Any more questions, guys?
All right, good. I'll see you guys next
class.